Wanna save time and money while grooming your dogs?
Check out this grooming kit that I found on TikTok Shop.
It literally sucks away the hair while you're grooming your dog.
I have four dogs here on the farm
and the first one up is Lieutenant Dan.
He is a Bernese mountain dog and Great Pyreneese mix
and he has an extremely dense double coat.
I love the slicker brush attachment
that just sucks the hair right into the canister.
There's also a little clean up tool
so any hair that dropped on the floor from the dog
can easily be cleaned up.
I also love this razor attachment
because he does get these mats behind his ears
and that easily cut them off and work on his Grinch feet.
The slicker brush easily work through his mats
and the vacuum canister is so quiet.
After our enjoyable pamper session
he is back out on the pasture for work.
Click that orange card to receive yours a free shipping!